I graduated college feeling like a total
boss-lady Club leadership student
government and let's not forget one of
those fancy management consulting jobs
you know them I walked across that stage
at graduation feeling ready to take on
the world within a year though that
confidence had disappeared I watched as
each one of my peers got staffed on cool
new projects while I sat and staffed
after each project interview that
resulted in no project offer I asked
myself what's wrong with me I don't they
want you when I eventually did get
staffed my manager was cold and critical
I remember my heart beating as I walked
to his desk to ask a question making
myself small and unobtrusive
this timidity followed me to my second
project but this one had a lot more
client interaction and all of a sudden
my feedback read lacks executive
presence I internalized this feedback
but without a mentor to show me how it
was done or somebody giving me guidance
on how to actually change all I did was
keep fixating on the fact that I was
inadequate I didn't feel ready to take
on my job much less the world anymore
my confidence was gone that intrinsic
untouchable belief in myself that I had
started my career with had vanished
replaced by fear that I wasn't enough
doubt that I had a future in the
business world and jealousy of everyone
around me who seemed to fit in and have
it figure it out my confidence stayed
low even as my performance improved
enough to get me here to the GSP with
all of you incredible people during my
MBA one year I stumbled across some
research that changed my own perspective
on my experiences it turns out what I
had gone through starting my career with
relatively high confidence and then
losing it with time that's actually
startling ly normal women enter the
workforce with confidence roughly equal
to that of their male peers
whit's high men's confidence remains
steady but the number of women who
believe they have what it takes to
succeed is cut in half it's something
called the confidence cliff this
phenomenon in which women actually lose
confidence once they've started work
there's a lot of potential explanations
everything from a lack of female role
models and mentors in the workplace
lessons taught to young girls about what
it means to be a good girl the
transition from an educational
experience that's relatively
straightforward to a work environment
that's politically fraught and which
like favors like all of these factors
and more come together to trip women up
until they have fallen off the cliff
and look this isn't something happening
out there to faceless nameless people it
happens here too in fact when I surveyed
the women in our community almost 90
percent said that they had experienced a
moderate or big decline in confidence 90
percent okay this sucks
we know that confidence is critical for
success without it women are less
ambitious less impactful and less likely
to get that next big promotion but
here's the thing when women lose we all
lose our organizations miss out on the
talent of half of their talent pool and
our leadership becomes less diverse with
worse outcomes as a result but beyond
the organizational impact and the
professional impact it also just fuels
really shitty I hate the feeling of
doubting myself
I hate that in addition to doing my job
I'm also fighting this battle with
confidence but more than anything I hate
the thought of each new generation of
women falling off the same cliff that
we've been falling off of for
generations this has to stop for the
class of 2018 2019 2020 2021 2022 and
beyond for them I'm standing up here
today and I invite you to stand with me
look right here in this room we have the
future business leaders of the world and
an awful lot of people who are going to
be managing teams in the next few years
when surveyed every single one of the
women said that having a supportive
manager or mentor would have had a
significant impact on her confidence of
those half so that it would even be
game-changing you have the ability to be
game-changing for the young woman on
your team don't be like my first manager
who didn't even see that I was falling
off the confidence cliff right in front
of him get to know that young woman on
her team
take her out to coffee mentor her or
introduce her to someone who can realize
that your sponsorship will be
game-changing not just for others see
her but for how she sees herself and
look all of your energy effort and time
on this will pay back to you tenfold not
only will you get a more effective
member of your team
but her loyalty to you will propel you
through the organization I know that all
of you are wonderful and you're gonna go
out there and be incredible leaders who
fight the confidence cliff along with
the women on your teams but we've also
got to start talking to the women
themselves look this is the group of
people who are so powerful so confident
when they start their careers we've got
to give them the tools and insight they
need to keep that confidence
so for all the women in this room who
might be trying to overcome the
confidence cliff and even for the 21
year-olds on the other side of that
camera still feeling on top of the world
and about to start your first big job in
a few months you are powerful you can
take on the world if I could give any
advice to my 21 year old self as I
walked across that stage at graduation
this is what I would say first find your
mentor and get advice on how to guide
your particular manager to be a better
Ally for you second don't fall into that
same critical thinking that I had during
the first few years of my career instead
see feedback as an opportunity for
growth I know I know
feedbacks a gift right but really though
now I realized that it was my fixed
mindset that meant that I internalized
the feedback I was given as a
condemnation of my potential and thus a
blow to my confidence instead practice
growth mindset which is all about
embracing your ability and even your
imperative to evolve and if that growth
takes a while go easy on yourself and
last get your awareness up for me just
knowing the confidence cliff was a thing
made me a less guilty for experiencing
it but be more motivated to rebuild my
confidence I didn't want to be just
another stat about gender inequality for
you
I hope knowing about the cliff makes you
more proactive and fighting it but also
lets you know you're not alone
we're all fighting this together on
behalf of all the generations of women
that we will bring up behind us so
overcome the confidence cliff and go
forward into the world I believe in you
I'll keep believing in yourself thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]